hi guys today I'm going to talk about
whether you should learn a language that
is a marketable skill or a language that
is quote unquote useless good evening
guys how are you doing today so you are
interested in learning languages you've
looked into it you think it's a
interesting thing to do you want to be
bilingual but you are wondering which
language to learn
maybe you should study Spanish because
there are lots of Spanish speakers maybe
you should study Chinese because Chinese
will be the language of the 21st century
some people say maybe you should study
Arabic because there are lots of Arabic
speakers speakers in lots of countries
maybe you should choose one of those but
maybe you're interested in Burmese maybe
for some reason yours you want to learn
Burmese or maybe you're interested in
Hebrew which is only spoken in Israel or
maybe you're interested in Esperanto
which is spoken nowhere maybe you have
some kind of desire or some interest to
learn some language that's not really
spoken that widely or spoken in a lot of
places so a lot of people ask me which
kind of language they should study the
first foreign language that I ever
studied was Hebrew and that's a language
that's only spoken in one place only in
this room pretty much so it's not a
language that was really all that useful
for me in a lot of places unless I met
some Israeli people here and there and
spoke Hebrew with them basically it was
just I learned it out of irrational
cultural interest I became interested in
that country and in that language and I
really wanted to study it and people at
the time said why don't you study French
why don't you study Spanish or why don't
you study Chinese and I kind of tried to
do that but I was always drawn back to
Hebrew because that's where my interest
was so I couldn't really focus on the
other line
so I think that's really the answer to
this dilemma of which length which kind
of language to study it's study the one
that you are passionate about the one
that you can focus on the one that
engages you because learning a language
is well if we're talking about learning
a language full-on like all in to learn
it well then that's a process that takes
quite a while you have to work at it
over a couple of years a few years if
we're talking about getting really good
at it right including being literate you
can be conversant in a few months but if
you want to if you want to be really
good at it all language skills that
takes longer than that so if your own
land if your long term in a language
then you have to be really interested in
it you have to be motivated and that
motivation comes from just your your
deep interest that irrational irrational
magnetism of that language that you feel
right if you decide to learn a language
because it's a marketable skill that's
what some people think they should do
they want to learn a language because
someday in the future it might be
marketable it might be useful on my
resume it might help me get a job well
it probably won't because first of all
you won't have the motivation to stick
with it most likely when you learn a
language through a lot of speed bumps
along the way right it's never just a
smooth road there are always times when
your skill drops there are times when
there's a plateau for a long time it's a
plateau you get frustrated sometimes
because your level isn't improving now
if you really love the language then you
just fight through it you stick it out
because that's a welcome challenge but
if you're not really interested in the
language in the first place if you're
just learning it because someday it
might be useful on my resume then you're
going to say screw it and give up
probably so the best thing is is to
stick with the language that your
interests
if you happen to be passionate about a
major global language like Spanish or
Chinese or maybe Arabic or one of these
then consider yourself lucky because you
will have the motivation that comes from
from your interest in the language but
at the end of the road you will have
that skill that can be applied to
potentially to a lot of different jobs
or travel in a lot of different places
so you lucked out your interest landed
in the right place unfortunately you
can't control where your interest lands
but you were lucky so go with that if
that's the case if you happen to be
interested in less commonly spoken each
language Hebrew or Burmese or whatever
like I said something that's only spoken
at one country go with that anyway there
are a lot of benefits you can get one of
the benefits is that you learn how to
learn languages you learn the process of
learning a language maybe now I'm
learning Hebrew that was the case for me
my first foreign language I was learning
Hebrew but I learned how to study right
I learned what you need to put in I
learned about the consistency I learned
about how to study vocabulary I learned
about the importance of training my my
ears and connecting my brain and my
mouth for world communication I learned
all these things that I applied to later
languages so now even though I don't
really use Hebrew that often except to
listen to Hebrew media on the internet
it still helped me because it helps me
learn other languages now
so that was my base it was where I
gained my understanding of how how to
learn languages how to follow that
process so that was the beginning for me
and it helped also um it's just a
wonderful hobby to have right when you
learn a niche language like that one
that's only spoken in one country why
not then many people they appreciate it
so much
like when I learned Hebrew and I spoke
to Hebrew speakers they couldn't believe
it they they wondered why I would speak
their language out of all the languages
in the world
why our language they'd asked me to say
they'd say are you Jewish and I'd say no
I'm not Jewish and then
even more shocked which I always found
kind of funny but that opened up a lot
of just a lot of friendships and a lot
of great interactions with people and I
got to know a lot of people really well
because they were just so impressed that
I loved their culture and loved their
language so it's just a great experience
to be all in in a language that not that
many people are studying because you
really stand out to the people who speak
it another thing is a niche language can
you ironically be more marketable than a
major language right if in your company
if 50 people speak Spanish like in
Southern California I don't know how
much of a marketable skill it is to
study Spanish as a second language so
many other people speak it and I'm from
Vancouver in Vancouver if I studied
Chinese Mandarin or Cantonese probably
that's not really a marketable skill for
me because so many other native speakers
live there and they're bilingual in
English too so they'll always have a leg
up on me so it's not really marketable
but if I knew Burmese or I knew Thai is
Thais not a minor language but it's only
spoken really in Thailand if I learn
Thai let's say then that might be more
marketable in my company because
probably not that many other people
speak Thai so if we're doing business
with Thailand I could be the person the
only person who can fill that position
right so don't assume that initial
anguish can't be marketable you might
have to look around and see how you can
market it but it's not necessarily
unmarketable some people learn a
language for for a slightly different
kind of motivation they they're really
motivated by a goal or their dream not
necessarily the language itself but the
language helps them achieve their dream
now here's what I mean I have some
acquaintances or some of my students
here I teach at a university it's done
some of my students are studying to be
flight attendants
and they have to speak English to be a
flight attendant they don't really care
about learning in English itself
necessarily but they want to be flight
attendants that's their dream job
they've they've sought after since they
were kids
always wanted that job so to help
achieve their dream they need English
though the dream motivates them to learn
the language so if you have a dream like
that if you have some goal for the
future
then maybe you should look at what
language might fit in with that goal and
then that's the one you go with because
your dream or goal will will provide the
motivation and passion that will drive
you and push you through all those speed
bumps along the way and give you that
long-term vision for studying the
language so if you are I don't know if
you're a filmmaker and you love French
films and you really want to go to the
Cannes Film Festival you want to snooze
or work with French filmmakers then
maybe French is the language for you
right I have a friend who's a musician
and she often travels to Austria because
she says that the best instructors are
the best piano mentors or in Austria at
least the ones she knows in I know
Austria is well known for orchestras and
for music in general so she's studying
German because that that helps her live
out her dream or achieve her dream more
fully by being in Austria right so
that's the language for her so whatever
language helps you achieve your dream
might be the best one for you so the
basic point is go with your passion
unfortunately you don't choose your
interests your interests choose you so
if you're if you were chosen by an
interest in Chinese or Spanish then good
for you if you were chosen by Esperanto
then sucks to be you but you're going to
enjoy it because that's your passion so
go with it and maybe in the future you
will choose a different language we use
a lot of what you learned and reapply
all of that new knowledge and experience
all right so that's what I would say and
go with your passion and don't ignore
that advice because you won't stick it
out all right thanks